This is Baikonur, the world's first and
largest operational spaceport.
The story of Baikonur begins in the early years of the
20th century when a small village
called Tyuratam was founded to service the
Moscow to Tashkent railway
This unforgiving corner of the world where
the winters are blisteringly cold,
the summer's searingly hot and even small
breezes can whip up dust storms over
the endless planes proved to be the
perfect location for the proposed Soviet
rocket testing facility. This is where
the world's first satellite, sputnik, was
launched in 1957 where
the world's first space dog Laika
started her space journey and where Yuri Gagarin made history by becoming the
first man in space.
While initially no more than a temporary military
installation, Tyuratam was quickly
built up into a town to support the Cosmodrome.
They built living quarters for the
workers and their families, schools,
and infrastructure to sustain a growing
population.
The Cosmodrome was named Baikonur after
a small mining town over 400 kilometers
away from Tyuratam, allegedly to confuse
and mislead their Cold War rivals, the United States.
The rules didn't quite
work as the USA could establish the
launch location based on the rocket
trajectory and later even found the town
using an observation jet by simply
following the railroad and seeing where it led.
Nevertheless, the town remained
locked down for decades and has only
recently opened up to allow admission to
tourists and space aficionados.
But what's next for Baikonur? Russia has an
agreement with Kazakhstan to use the
Cosmodrome until 2050 but also has plans
to build a new site in Vostochny
in the Russian Far East by 2018. Kazakhstan Space Agency is hopeful that
a new development of a launch complex
called Baiterek will revitalize the area
ensuring the ongoing launch program of
satellites and commercial flights.
The legacy of the world's first and largest
spaceport will live on.